so this is possibly the most honest to
be title for a topic ever um it's not
just rapping it's harder graphic okay
now let's just call that line that we've
been graphic for a very very long time I
want you to think about the families of
functions that you turn about graphic
just calm down so we'll give you an
example of a kind of graph that you
don't have that okay Brava song you know
me
Lidia okay right I heard a second one a
third one over here I'm going to perform
promote to that one I heard Lidia I
heard parabolas I'm actually going to
lock them together into the same family
of cuz it is a few others that are in
the same family these are all polynomial
functions up it so you told me about
linear functions degree one told me
about
brothers which have degree 2 there you
can go cubics cortex quit tics etc
they're all the same they are polynomial
curves these are the very first things
that we learned how to graph okay they
were also the very first things we learn
how to differentiate and then find all
of them I had another one starting with
H who said revenue hyper those thank you
very much hi puddle is quite different
polynomials have no discontinuity to
give them and hyperbolas I they kind of
characterized by by having those
speeches left okay there should be at
least one upskill we draw circles thank
you very much circles are weird because
I like almost everything else that you
can draw at the moment circles are not
even functions what are they they're
they're relations right but you don't
just have a single value going to a
single Y value you've got a single x
value going into our pair Y values
generally speaking
okay polynomials hyperbola circles
Exponential's their Exponential's they
have a kind of twin brother twin sister
which are lockers right I'm going to
lock them together because they really
are the same family of curve the same
family of graph just looked at from a
[ __ ] perspective what's the last one so
far you might think they wave around a
lot we've looked at them is yes we
looked at they become based on this
trigonometric functions right these guys
are pretty important so this more or
less excuse me
all the kinds of functions families of
functions that we'd be looking at now I
can't I can't add on to this ah absolute
values however I hope you recognize it
actually actually values are not a
family of graph are they they're a theme
that you do to other kinds of graphs
does that make sense and I'm going to
come back that point in it so what does
hot about included well it doesn't
include more families of graphs what
it's basically doing is taking these
guys and exploring what it is to [ __ ]
with them a little bit and there are
four different ways in which we explore
that okay so the easiest one is what we
would call geometric and it's all to
look at today
geometric transformations now I want you
to think all the way back to you seven
when transformations were something that
you like to do with shapes okay there
are three transformations actually that
you learn to do with shifted here or
what they are I can't I have a reflect
I'm gonna rotate and
what more which sounds very simple to
transform translate okay
now each of these three what we said was
important about them is that they change
the shape in some way but the size stays
the same and what you the features of
the shape so in other words you get a
cone shape okay now let the grass the
two of those three that we're going to
focus on are we today
reflection and translation as it happens
with the kinds of things we know how to
graph rotation is actually surprisingly
difficult to do so we leave off of them
okay so geometric transfer patient
revisions the other the second thing we
learn about doing is about composing
graphs now what do I mean by composing
when you say oh this is composed of blah
blah blah blah or there's a he's a
musical composition or there's a musical
composer is that me
we often use their music upon us we
bought these and I'm going to compose a
piece that means I'm going to make a
piece okay but actually composing a
piece is made up or something that you
know uses the word can post more
generally like if I say a Rockies can
pose on water the chemicals can post off
or you say yeah in fact anytime you see
like that that's suffix right like Co
interior of course when it's when things
are sort of jammed together right so
when you are composing graphs what I
mean is well you could take any of these
guys any of these guys and you could um
you could add them together right you
could take a trig function and you could
add it to say a linear curve right and
you would get a new shape you can add
them together you could subtract this
you could multiply them you could okay
so all of these ways all these functions
over here you can combine that you can
compose them in these variety of ways
that's the first to the last to sort of
hang together a little bit we're also
going to look at powers of functions
powers of graphs so if you take one of
these right thanks a graphics bit of
trouble right well the graphic below you
what happens if you take that whole
thing and square the whole thing or cube
the whole thing or apply a square root
2v or take the reciprocal of the whole
thing which would be what power
like what did one on the signage looks
like look at we actually have a special
day for mothers limit per se right so
what does that look like
maybe explored some of these before but
does anyone know what one elec along X
looks like or one on excuse where you
don't look at all these famous luncheons
the last one and interesting I may not
do it last will say because actually
very useful to extension one is a
technique for understanding graphs
better and it's it's more broadly
applicable than that too but this is the
first place you meet it called implicit
differentiation now just as with many
other things in the extensions of course
it is into attempted to intimidate you
just by its names nothing fancy it's
actually a special use of the chain rule
but it's something that comes into the
context though like the circles right so
what's the equation give me an example
equation so now if I were to ask you to
find the gradient of a curve we know how
to do that we could do that in a sling
behind on that but when you look at
something like this you like of a second
I don't like things written like this
I like things written like this equals
of all the X's over there all the X's
over there
right why do what do you do with this
thing now you can this thing you do a
couple of things with that one of the
nicest way to do with it is this thing
called implicit differentiation you want
another gradient but it seems we don't
looking for or you can still work with
that if you're happy to load some new
tools okay